everyone welcome back to game Sports
coverage of e3 2017 joining Oscar and
myself here on the demo stage is Paul
from super Lucky's tale I was going to
say from playful corporate super lucky
stuff yes how is your III going it's
been great we were just talking about
how I haven't got to play as many games
as I'd like because we've been busy
showing off they get to show off your
own that's true that's true what was
what was a reception like after coming
out on the the Xbox press conference
stage been just so positive I was
talking to the director the game's name
is Dan and he told me there was a neogaf
thread about the game and I was like oh
no I don't want to see this actually but
I got online and it's like super full of
love and and you know people are kind of
already falling in love with lucky and
they're excited about a platformer
coming to the Xbox and that's the best
thing ever cuz you know like we knew
coming into this that that we had a game
that that like kids would love and my
kids would love but we've been really
working hard to also create something
that gamers would love to and making
sure the game had enough skill and
challenge and and what the controls were
tight and all that kind stuff and now to
see the hands-on that people are playing
the game and they're saying it's
actually a great platformer so yes that
must have been great to have been on
Microsoft stage 83 right I was the bells
major yeah
like an amazing opportunity for you guys
and by all accounts the reception has
been really good I was interested to
hear what changes can people expect from
people who played the original game yeah
you know this has obviously been
repurposed and now it's an xbox one
called console exclusive what changes
can people expect if they'd already
played the original one what can they
expect going in some people's their
people should expect a full-blown sequel
so there's a little bit confusion about
that online right now but but super
lucky sell is not a poor or you know
translation of the first game we started
from scratch and built this game it's
completely new experience you know it's
it's got a brand new set of levels even
the new set of moves for lucky tons of
new minigames and bosses and completely
new cast of characters so what if you
didn't get the opportunity to play the
first game is there gonna be something
for you in the second game also don't
like refresh every a little bit yeah so
um you know the story really of lucky
still is more about the characters right
and super Lucky's tale has a completely
new cast
characters that weren't even in the
first game especially the villains the
the nefarious jinx who's that big cat
that shows up at the end of the trailer
and then his kids which are called the
kitty litter and they're the ones
causing all the trouble in the different
worlds they're all new so so people can
come into this game and they don't need
to necessarily know anything about the
games that came before they can just
dive right in but presumably there's
going to be a few nods and winks to
Africa originally the biggest thing
actually you know when we were
developing the game for VR one of the
things that that ended up being really
delightful is that lucky was actually
aware of you so like he would look up at
you and you'd look down on him and if
you're kind of leaning around he would
watch you and he'd wave at you we
actually kept that alive in Super
Lucky's tale and so now he's like
peering out of the TV at you and waving
actually works really well I'm surprised
that more games don't do this I mean I
guess it's like breaking the fourth wall
but we've always talked about how the
player the gamers relationship to lucky
is kind of like Calvin and Hobbes so
like you're his imaginary friend and he
knows you're there and so he's like come
on help me out you know and and that's
actually it works really well on a TV
also yeah it seems like these days are
platforming games are having somewhat of
a resurgence he had died lei Li you have
crash coming back what's it been like
sort of coming into that space as a
relatively new creepy um it was a little
scary to be honest that especially
because you know I think both US and
Microsoft had this this secret hope that
that gamers wanted this kind of game on
xbox but we weren't sure you know and
and but Microsoft really had the faith
and took a chance and put lucky right in
the middle of their press briefing and
and it paid off like our hypothesis was
it is time for this gamers have always
wanted this on their Xbox and and now
that we can see the reaction it's like
okay good yes we people do want this
kind of game what do you think I mean
certainly I mean loose loose
dimensionally there it feels like 3d
platforms are having the same sort of
resurgence that CD platform has had yeah
yeah three or four years ago yeah why do
you think they sort of receded into the
background a bit and why do you think
they're now having that research I don't
know I was talking to somebody the other
day and there's like it's like the
15-year rule you know it's like you have
the peek of something in any kind of you
got
let it rest for a while and then people
are ready for it again and it comes back
I actually think it's kind of has to do
with the cycle of you know like so I'm I
just turned 40 and I have kids that are
nine seven and and four years old hi
Eloise Arthur and cubby anyway and and
so like when we look at Lucky's tale
Super Lucky's tale we're actually sort
of I believe building a game for two
audiences at the same time or building a
game for these kind of 30 and 40 year
old folks like me who grew up playing
games like this and we're finally at the
age now where where we have a little
more time and we can actually play with
our kids and so we care a lot about
those gamers but we're also if we do it
right we're building a game for a new
generation of gamers to fall in love
with the same way that we did when we
were kids and I remember my favorite
experience was like you'd get a new
console and you under the Christmas tree
and you'd open it up and like that thing
you wanted to play that what you were
waiting for to plug into that console
was a platforming game right and I think
people are ready for it again do you
think that's is that tricky to try and
develop a game this for to audiences is
very that comes down to everything right
from like the marketing to the writers
the actual development of the game
itself like that must be a really
difficult thing I think yes I I think
that that for us we just can't think too
hard about it like because we can get
kind of too caught up in like you said
like trying to cater to certain
audiences and I think that the real
trick for us is to just be genuine to
look at lucky our studio we fall in love
with the characters we create and it's
not even just about lucky even the
secondary characters in the game
secondary characters like the villains
we put so much love and thought and we
hope some day that each one of them
could have their own game you know if we
do it right and and I think when we're
genuine like that that then it works if
we think too hard about it then you know
it starts to be probably like we're
forcing it sure have you been getting
your own kids into play test oh yeah of
course what do they what do they make of
it cuz it is like the coolest job you
think my dad makes video game they love
it but but you know they're also like
kind of our harsh critics right like if
we had an earlier version of jinx that
the main villain in the game and he
wasn't cute enough really
kind of looked a little too evil and
they were like dad now not and I was
like yeah sorry that one's going back to
the trying work so they they must have
really loved being able to do that but
how have you found it if you giving it
to giving it to other groups of players
as well has the reception being the same
from them I assume adults aren't going
in having quite the same like why die
okay kids right that's right I mean it's
different right does it get a little
more skeptical but actually this show
has been the the big debut for that and
the our biggest opportunity to watch a
bunch of gamers in a counter the game
and and to just you know have to stand
back and see what they're going to say
about it and watch their reactions and
Microsoft had that had this kind of
showcase event after the press briefing
that the second day and we had waves of
press and then youtubers coming through
and and then like Xbox fans and these
are like the hardest core Xbox fans and
they were just flocking to the game and
then and then we're like getting on
Twitter and talking about you know how
much they they were happy that this game
was coming to Xbox and so so like I said
we weren't sure that that was the
reaction that we were going to get but
we're so happy that it is how difficult
is it been going from developing the
original Lucky's tale for exclusively
for VR yeah so now developing the sequel
in as far as I'm aware doesn't know via
version that's right that must be a
weird shift right it is weird but there
are two really great things that came
out of it so the first one is more
technical but running on VR we had to so
you know it's a headset has two screens
actually so we had to render the game
twice I had to run at 90 frames per
second so we had to put all this work
into getting the game to perform really
well so then when Microsoft shows up
with this amazing Xbox dev kit which
used to be called Project Scorpio it was
like yeah we can do 4k 60 frames per
second no problem we already because we
had to run in 90 frames per second
before so this is just me and then the
the Xbox one X itself is such a beast
that it's like literally almost the
first time we got it running it was
already running at 4k 60 Hertz you know
so that's one thing the second thing is
when we were developing the game in VR
there was these things we were concerned
about as far as how comfortable it was
and we didn't want to rotate
camera because that would make you sick
and uncomfortable in VR so we had to
design our levels so that you're always
facing in one direction and yet we
wanted the it's still to be kind of an
open-world platformer those kind of
games that have more of a sense of
adventure more nonlinear taking that
design now and carrying it forward into
Super Lucky's tale means that the game
doesn't require you to mess with the
camera so and you don't get lost you
know the cameras not spinning around
it's generally always facing in one
direction in fact you don't even have to
touch the camera controls at all if you
don't want to but the game is still
nonlinear so when you play the demo here
on the show floor you'll see it's not
just run from point A to point B you
kind of have these quests you got to go
get these little baby Gollum heads and
bring them back to their bodies and wake
up this giant golem and this other stuff
that you can see in the trailer
and that came directly from what we
learned making the game for VR Wilson so
you touched on Xbox one X there which
was sort of the big reveal of yeah III
how has it been working with that I mean
we only got glimpses of it at Microsoft
showcase but it sounds like you've had
access to it for a little while yeah
this is from a developer standpoint this
is the most developer friendly console
we have ever worked with and not just
because the hardware is super
overpowered which it is it's just like
ridiculous I mean I don't understand how
they it's like a high-end PC crammed
into this tiny little box but also like
the tools and again it's getting a
little more technical but the tools and
support that we we have when we're
developing the game is like the most
advanced that's ever been and I think
that's just because Microsoft hasn't
necessarily been reinventing every time
they've just been refining and making it
more powerful so they get to carry
forward and and this is kind of the best
version of yet of the Xbox Olson so do
you think we'll ever see of the our
version of that's the question that
everyone wants to know I funding around
I think I hear the same things you guys
here right so last year Microsoft talked
about how they were excited about mixed
reality and virtual reality this year
it's really the story is all about the
Xbox one X and that's I think what
gamers are most excited about but I like
you guys can't wait to sort of stay
tuned and see what happens in the future
what do you think about the the current
state of VR games because
you get sort of like you know obviously
Sony had that big push with PlayStation
VR but it seems like there aren't really
that many fully fledged games out there
there are like add-on modes or demos
demos yeah do you think that's good
that's gonna change and but it it has to
change absolutely think so
you know there's there's some folks
online that have been talking about oh
you know there's not enough VR
announcements at the show so maybe VR is
like dying or whatever no no that the
right way to look at it is this year is
more of like a building year as what we
would call like an investment year this
is the year when when companies who are
working on these technologies are taking
their time so that and I met you know I
think gamers like we all have cell
phones so we're used to like every year
I want a new thing I want the new device
right and that it was just last year
that the kind of first generation of VR
devices launched and everybody's like
great so this year will be the next like
version 2 but I don't think that VR is
going to work like mobile phones I think
it's going to be you know there's going
to be a couple years between major new
releases of hardware but from what I can
tell there's more investment and more
excitement and more things being built
for VR than there ever have been before
I think it's because uh when
particularly during the oculus is
development it seemed like there would
be a new dev kit video every few months
and so people be like oh so this is how
VI was gonna go right it's gonna be
updated all the time it's funny even
when we were working with oculus um you
know they kind of originally were hoping
to ship the rift a year before they did
but they decided you know if we just
wait another year we can get better
tracking technology better technology
and I think that's what's happening with
companies that are working on these
devices now they're like well if we just
maybe we wait till next year we can get
facial tracking or we can get eye gaze
tracking or these other things and
Wireless like that you heard actually I
think was Phil at Microsoft talking
about you know maybe four console VR
Wireless is the thing and that would be
great because I don't know if you guys
have tried it but when you have a
wireless VR headset it's like a whole
new feeling of freedom so yeah all these
technologies are being built right now
and and I think we'll start I guess
we'll start to see next next-generation
devices coming out probably next year
that must be the same with you guys even
just shipping a game though right like
there's always new technology coming yes
with better graphics is always more
power at some point you've just got to
ship the thing you'd be surprised though
because
the thing that actually has more of an
impact than anything is the controller
right so it's really nice that the
controllers aren't changing that much
anymore although except in VR you've got
hand track controllers and stuff and
that's all of a sudden you know creating
a whole new but but yeah like as a game
designer that the most my starting point
when I think about what kind of game I
want to make is just I'm gonna close my
eyes just put a controller in my hand
and then I'll tell you what I want to
make for it and and when you put a
controller in my hand that has a thumb
stick I'm like I won't take a platformer
you know that's that's where lucky still
came from what do you want the the
legacy of super Lucky's tale to be you
know do you want it to become the next
big well obviously you wanted to become
a next big yeah that's all y'all do yeah
I am I want I want people I'd love for
people to fall in love with lucky like
we have and to create a lifelong
relationship with that character because
I mean technologies come and go and
platforms come and go but you know look
at like what happened with Pokemon last
year right this is a brand that just
celebrated his 25th anniversary or
whatever it was the biggest game on
phones and phones hadn't been invented
when Pokemon was birth care all right I
think that was gay MERS that's the
relationships we actually form are with
the characters and the stories and and
so that's why we're putting so much love
and care into those characters that
we're making in those stories we're
telling is to hopefully establish
relationships so that the the
eight-year-olds who are going to open
their Xbox is this Christmas and play
this game want to play it 20 years from
now with decades with their kids exactly
well thank you so much for joining us
when can we get our hands on Super
Lucky's tale November 7th $29.99 awesome
thank you so much for joining us thank
you for having me and guys for more from
this year's e3 make sure you stay tuned
to game spot calm